you got your skill levels here one you
have no power I need you to try for
power so your your the tents everything
up to help it keep maintain organization
and you're gonna move your Center if you
can get that what you want to do now is
let go of the like gold attention okay
and shrinking how much external movement
so on his body so I don't want to try
and level two and you're like right do
you understand do you get you understand
what I'm saying doesn't so I'm relaxing
but the the effect on you does not look
relaxed you see so level one level one I
relaxed but he had the same force going
to his party that's what you're trying
to do let's go
nobody's throwing light that's what
we're saying so we and a certain point
we have to stop doing technical training
technical training is introductory
training we already know this inward
spiral so my arm ends here with the
outer elbow point the upper inner point
at the end of the tent you have to stop
doing this
so you just the four try to not be
afraid in the same way that I might
start relaxing you have to relax
you can't let your body fear Drive you
into unconsciousness you notice how
you're starting far away now did you
notice that missus okay do you see what
I mean
so the my is prescribed if you go like
what by I'm afraid okay consciousness
[Music]
I gotta get I gotta gather you so same
thing number 100 I don't care and you
start getting it
same for Southwick one say force
Tuesday's for the way it should be